most of the things that I guess other
people might see is failure I don't say
it's failure what's a failure I really
didn't do well like I choked on a hair
while I was talking and I guess a lot of
the things that most people would see is
failure I don't see as failure I don't
even see this feedback it just was and
now we're moving on I Don't Look
Backwards right it's like okay whatever
that's done cool let's go forward oh you
have feedback for me cool I filmed
without the microphone was out of
failure I see it as a win I don't think
I take big enough risks to ever have a
real failure like if I mortgaged my
house to make this day like insane and
Danny says Hey to make this thing fly we
need Val Kilmer riding in an elephant
like crashing through the front door and
then that had to work or I lost my house
that's a failure to me so everything
else is all manageable I think it's a
strength and a weakness it limits how
much upside I have but this also means a
zero downside need motivation watch the
top 10 believe Nate
Nation Carmichael and I make these
videos because of my first business I
quit on my business partner I struggled
to keep going I was making 300 bucks a
month and felt like a complete failure
and the thing that saved me that pulled
me up was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today you get to learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules for Success enjoy
rule number two is change your
environment the fastest way to change
your habits is to change your
environment you ever notice how when
you're in a different environment maybe
you go on vacation maybe you go to an
event or seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars or those those are
options but it starts with you figuring
out well what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too rule number three is Chase
fulfillment you don't know what the
final product is you're trying to get
because if it's an internal fulfillment
if it's a feeling you can't quantify
that and if you can't quantify it you
can't reverse engineer it so my mind is
wired numbers
but like my heart is going more towards
the the helping and serving but you
can't map that out to break down steps
so it's like an it's like a it's like a
dichotomy I hear you
but you you kind of can in that
the feeling of fulfillment that you're
chasing
how many times when you've been in a
room
with a lot of people or just with one
person that you've helped do you leave
feeling
more fulfilled
often so that's how you quantify it put
you in a room with somebody who needs
help
and you'll eighty percent of the time
come out with more fulfillment that's
what I said like that's the missing
piece because you're not feeling the
connection you're all push push push and
no hug it's like you need the feeling
because okay I had a thousand Instagram
followers now two thousand or whatever
it is like it doesn't mean enough
because it's a momentary you cross that
number but there's no heart
the heart is when you're talking and
you're actually very good at you say I'm
all you're not just all mine you're
great at connecting to people and
helping them
you do it naturally
more than anybody on my whole tour
we did in every city I went across
America you were like the most the only
guy who didn't talk about himself and
like used his time to help the other
people
so you're naturally great at it you're
just not putting yourself in the
position to do it
and so you can XO quantify it if you
were to twice a week do something with
somebody else who needs help
80 of the time you're going to come out
feeling more fulfilled like I'm I'm
Kick-Ass at what I do I'm so happy that
I had that conversation with that person
because you're actually good at it and
it's like if you sucked at it then it
might be 25 but you're actually really
good at it so 80 90 of the time you're
going to come out feeling more fulfilled
which then gives you the courage and the
motivation to then stay consistent
because you're all push but there's no
consistency when you can match the push
in the hug then you'll stay consistent
because you're you feel that it's
fulfilling
if you're not fulfilled you won't say
consistent
it's just little thing to chase like I'm
going to start and stop in certain stuff
right if you actually felt fulfilled in
the work like this is Meaningful this
was really cool I want to do it again
you'll stay more consistent on all the
work rule number four is step out of
your comfort zone to change your life
you have to be willing to change your
actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing to do
different things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not comfortable doing that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day that's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it if it's just you but you don't want
to fail in front of other people and
that can no longer be a good enough
reason because if you only do think
about this if you only do what's
comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is learn new
things was it hard for you to dig inside
and say I'm going to work on Evan I love
taking on new things like you have a
different modality that you want to no
nobody's models ever quite fit me so
it's cool but I'm happy to try on the
next model you guys you have your eight
step personality test cool I'm a
electrifier awesome
you know like it never quite fits but
all of them are good
good pass like I'm not locked into one
modality like it's got to be the Colby
score it's got to be the Myers-Briggs
there's got to be the whatever but they
all teach you a little bit about
yourself even even down to
I just have my DNA tested and from the
DNA test they show you hey based on your
genes you're more susceptible to these
kinds of foods and this kind of activity
and all this kind of stuff like okay
those are like they're averages so it's
it's a good starting point
I love trying stuff I love trying stuff
for me to learn and also to to
demonstrate to other people that go try
stuff rule number six is stop doubting
yourself the biggest difference between
you and the people who you look up to
are that they started and you're still
thinking about it it's one of the most
frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs
that I deal with on a day-to-day basis
is that seeing so much potential in
people seeing so much heart and love and
care is like you you could be serving so
much and helping so much and having such
a big impact
and and we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too I was stuck it took
me forever to get started and I thought
I had to have the the perfect cameraman
my first video if you go back and watch
it on my channel I had my friend come
and film it and record it for me because
I was worried about it not being perfect
enough that I didn't know the gear and
didn't know the microphone and the
lighting and the setup and I I memorized
the script because I didn't want to say
the wrong words I had to be perfect uh
most of my early videos were were still
mostly voice over because I could write
a script and have it perfect and just
have b-roll and it wouldn't be me on
camera afraid of making a mistake and
saying the wrong things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow you know if
you look at my journey of
making what for five years seven
thousand subscribers something like that
it was I was stuck I was I was
I was too afraid to do the next thing I
was too afraid to get in the race I was
making content at least I was one decent
thing for whatever reason I stay
consistent on on doing stuff but I was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and
a lot of you are already way better than
than I was when I started
and when I'm on interviews and I'm I'm
doing events and presentations and I see
the audience and I see who's there and I
see the skill and the and the heart just
the this is the thing that kills me the
most it's like the hearts like you want
you've got such a good heart you want to
do so much
and then there's just no action there's
no momentum because of the fear if you
could make one change
this year that would really move the
needle it would be to stop judging
yourself for the content that you're
making or the product you're putting out
of the service and just expect it to
suck and keep going rule number seven is
help others how does a person for lack
of better terms a broken person
get over that to be able to help other
people that might be
when they themselves haven't healed yet
for me
[Music]
serving is part of the healing process
so
for me to heal and get better
I need to be helping others right so you
saw me on that tour
Pittsburgh was if it wasn't our first
time it was one of our first jobs was
number one first stop and then you went
to Cleveland the last stop and you saw
the difference between me Cleveland I
had my I had a broken neck I don't know
if you stuck away to the end like that I
was on the floor for 45 minutes just at
the end because like I was I was gone I
gave everything
but we had a real decision when I when I
had broken my neck like do I keep going
or go home and everybody was saying go
home like it's crazy you go home
everybody would understand if you go
home because you broke your neck you
could concussion all this but for me
I would get more healing by being with
people and helping them than me being on
the couch at home
just healing or feeling sorry for myself
or whatever and I had all sorts of
you know I was I was gaining lots of
weight because I wasn't moving around I
had like this giant scab on my forehead
I wasn't thinking as clearly as I
normally would be the events were worse
right I wasn't I didn't have the same
energy you saw me at the end in
Cleveland but I still didn't have as
much energy there as I did in Pittsburgh
when I first started because I I wasn't
moving around sitting there for four
hours with ice packs on me but that
became part of my healing process so for
me I actually healed more by being with
people and sitting with them and helping
them than by me being by myself I
haven't gone through any serious
depression or I haven't wanted to commit
suicide and some of the things that you
know you've talked about but one of my
favorite Expressions that I forget who
said it was like don't suffer alone you
know like when you're when you're alone
just and you when you're suffering sorry
just don't be alone reach out to
somebody have have a community have a
group have a friend so you're not by
yourself because you're you can do
stupid things when you're by yourself
when you're really in really dark places
and you've you pulled yourself off the
edge you know in there which is amazing
amazing but a lot of people don't you're
never fully healed I don't think but you
gain more healing as you continue to
help people at least that's what I tell
myself and what I find works for me rule
number eight is take on challenges your
challenges don't only make you stronger
they allow you to serve better I think
the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
they put in your way allow you to have a
a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and
the thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humor to build to serve you are
built to serve when you can connect the
challenge that you're going through as
something that's then going to inspire
and help other people
at least for me
it always gives me a lot more strength
and a lot more courage to do the thing
that I need to do as opposed to it just
being about me getting stronger I find a
lot of times me getting stronger is not
enough it's not enough of a reason
compared to it's going to help somebody
else as well so you know that's you hope
this video helps you as well so I think
about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life and that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
was my first ever tour and then I broke
my neck two-thirds of the way through
so as if things weren't hard enough now
I break my neck I can't drive anymore uh
I'm in insane amounts of pain I have a
concussion uh and I'm still making
videos I I struggled with the decision
this was a real decision do I do I quit
the tour or not do I quit the tour do I
go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but sucks
for everything else so what do we do the
thing that made me want to at least try
to keep going I didn't know that I would
go for another month but I thought let's
just do the next city let's just do the
next city let's go to Kansas City Kansas
City was the next stop let's go to
Kansas City and see what happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues
things like believe in you not good
enough lack of self-worth you don't have
a message to share imposter syndrome all
of those things right even here we're
filming we're about to go through a car
wash uh we're we're next so we're
probably gonna get some crazy noise
don't have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time rule number
nine is do things that scare you I
remember I was at a a video event
and there were these two brothers who
were speaking together okay who are
friends of mine and one of them was
seasoned and had like done tons of
events and presentations and the other
guy was his very first time ever doing a
presentation and they're on the main
stage they got a thousand people Plus in
the room and he's like freaking out his
brother and brother may not have been
making it better he's like oh yeah this
is easy and it's like it was easy for
you I'm I'm struggling and I told him to
just go out and actually say that you're
nervous
like just get on stage and yeah say I'm
nervous like this is my first time ever
speaking and I'm really nervous to be
here
because it makes you a lot more
relatable yes yeah and so so he said
that and some people clapped them up you
know for even admitting that and then at
the end he got so much love from
people's like that was your that was
amazing I can't believe that was your
first time ever doing it and by him
admitting it it relieved the pressure of
having to be perfect
right it's actually more of an
inspiration that you're willing to get
up there and risk failing yes than if it
was super easy for you to go off and do
the reason why I did my tour because I
was really afraid to do yes speaking yes
I said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do the
thing I'm most terrified about and I'm
gonna go speak every four days
I'm gonna host my own workshop and speak
every four days and who knows that
people are gonna show up and Rule Number
10 the last home before some very
special bonus Clips is take immediate
action the first question that came in
on the poll was how can we focus on one
thing with too much information
so at the beginning of anything it
always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that
seem overwhelming at the beginning and
it's frustrating to know which ads to
serve to which audiences and just
testing tests and test and testing until
I kind of get a sense of okay this is
where the gates are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
anyway so I hope that makes sense right
it's taking that big idea that seems
overwhelming that seems impossible and
then finding one step that you can do
today because as long as you have it as
some big dream in your head that is
impossible then you never take any
action and then you know it's a year
later and you still haven't done the
thing yet because it still seems too
impossible and I see it all the time
with entrepreneurs who are getting
started people ask you how do I get
started on YouTube how do I get started
as an author how do I get started as a
speaker and and you think you've got to
have this perfect plan and the perfect
gear and all of this perfect stuff and
then it's a year later and you still
haven't done the thing immediate action
momentum
the key to experimenting is expecting to
suck just expect to suck expected not to
work out expect it to be a total
disaster expect to suck
which gives yourself the permission to
go and try we're holding ourselves back
from trying because you may not expect
to be great but you expect to be pretty
good I think this is a problem for a lot
of entrepreneurs is you have an idea you
have a dream you don't think you're
going to be the next Jeff Bezos maybe
yes but maybe no you're going to make
your own YouTube channel you're not
going to be great on camera but you
expect to be pretty good
you know you don't expect to be Bezos
but you expect to be pretty good in your
business and what ends up happening is
you start and you realize oh my gosh I'm
not only
not Bezos level I'm I'm terrible
I see it all the time people who are
starting their YouTube channels they
don't expect to be terrible on camera
they don't expect to be whoever you
think is a great on-camera personality
and then they record themselves and if
they thought they'd be like an 8 out of
ten they don't expect to be 10 they
think there'd be eight
and then they watch it back like oh my
gosh I'm a two
I'm a two out of ten and then they stop
and they never release the video they
never try the next thing because they're
convinced that they just suck that they
suck as a human
and that they'll never get the skills
well how do you get the skills by
practicing by doing just because you
were two out of ten now doesn't mean you
can't become an eight or a nine or a ten
how do you get there how do you go from
a two to an eight or nine or ten at the
thing that you want to be great at by
practicing by learning by doing not just
by researching and studying and watching
other people you have to get into the
trenches and start to create and start
to make that's how you move
but people are too afraid to fail that
they don't even try
you're so afraid to fail that you don't
even try
and the way through it is expecting to
suck
I am right now learning about nfts and
now I know enough to be dangerous about
nfts but two months ago I didn't I knew
nothing I didn't know what it's what it
stood for non-fungible I don't even know
what a fungible token nothing made sense
I didn't understand what wag me meant I
didn't understand what lfg meant I
didn't understand what hoddle meant I
didn't know the difference between
Bitcoin or ethereum I didn't know what I
meant a mask while it was all of this
stuff zero idea and the more I I just
looked at it from the outside the more I
got
stressed out confused overwhelmed I
don't understand any of this stuff I
feel like a total beginner and so I'm
not going to learn it
and I want to be the person who jumps on
things who learns things it doesn't
accept scary difficult or hard as good
enough reasons for me not to do it so I
dove in
and I asked all those stupid questions
and I learned not just by reading about
it but by launching my own nft projects
and putting it out there and starting to
work with people I went into the
different discords and Twitter I didn't
even know what Discord was I wasn't
using Discord
nft land is Discord and Twitter I had to
install Discord and get active on it I
had to reignite my Twitter account like
you guys use Twitter I haven't used
Twitter for years but Twitter is where
the game is at so I'm picking up my
Twitter game again and I'm asking what
seems to be stupid questions I'm asking
all the beginner questions and I'm
launching my own nft project to learn to
understand and now I know enough to be
dangerous I'm not an expert at it but I
know enough to be dangerous
and that happened in a relatively short
amount of time because I was willing to
experiment and I was willing to expect a
sec at the beginning I'm gonna go in be
a total Noob right total total newbie
total beginner ask the questions and
then I'm going to learn through that
process and get better at it you can
surprise yourself with how much you can
learn
prize yourself with how much you can
learn at the beginning if you're just
willing to detach yourself that just
because you suck at a skill doesn't mean
that you suck as a human
this is where we get stuck it's like oh
I suck at that therefore I suck and I'm
never gonna get better so I'm going to
stop and go do something else that makes
me feel good
and sets you know I suck at this skill
and I feel good for trying and I'm going
to keep getting better at this so that I
can I can improve my skill from a two to
a two and a half to three to a five to
an eight to a ten
so how do we start to do it how do we
start to give ourselves more permission
to experiment give ourselves permission
to fail give ourselves permission to
suck how do we do it step number one
trust your ideas
trusted the ideas that come to you are
good trusted that idea that you're
thinking about right now is good just do
a quick gut check is are you trying to
rip people off are you trying to serve
and try to help are you trying to just
take their money put in your bank
account and go buy your boat or you're
trying to actually do some good right if
you're watching this channel hopefully
you're in the second category or you're
trying to serve you're trying to help
you're trying to create something of
value so if that is your intention then
trust your ideas stop holding yourself
back stop saying that you can't do it
stop finding all the reasons in your
head that you cannot take action because
your Heroes have done more with less
than what you already have right now
whoever your heroes are whoever you look
up to Jeff Bezos whoever Oprah Winfrey
whoever they started with less than what
you have right now they could do it you
can do it too
you can
so if the idea is a good one it's it's
it's it feels right it's heart Centric
you want to serve you want to bring
value to people then trust that idea
trust it step number two immediate
action
immediate immediate immediate action the
problem is we get stuck in overthinking
over planning over preparing over
strategizing over asking other people
well what do you think I should do stop
that immediate action what's the first
thing that you can do
if you want to get an nfts go join
somebody's Discord go launch your own
single nft you're going to make tons of
mistakes perfect launch it you want to
launch a podcast great start your
podcast today you want to create a
YouTube channel awesome pull out your
phone record your video You're a
YouTuber now right you want to launch a
fashion business perfect create a logo
make a t-shirt like just start
it doesn't have to be anything great
just start the biggest thing for most
people that's missing is just momentum
it's all of these things stuck in your
head and not enough being created in the
world
and to get all this organized and
structured and actually making sense you
have to actually put something out
so trust your ideas that they're good
that they're of value that they're they
will serve and then set number two is do
something about it immediate in the
moment action let's go stop overthinking
it and today something has to happen and
then step number three is just expect to
suck expect to suck expect it not to
work out expect not to make money on
this expect no comments no replies no
feedback expect to to just fail expect
it to be a total failure if you expect
that going in then you're not
you're not surprised when it doesn't
work out and you're not taking it
personally that you tried this thing and
nobody cares about it right now
you're lowering the burden for what has
to happen for you to feel good about
yourself
if you only feel good when you win then
you will never try
right if you will only take
a yes and enter that competition enter
that race or do that thing if you know
that you're going to win you will never
try you you will stay stuck doing the
easy stuff for the rest of your life and
never accomplish what you're capable of
never hit anywhere close to your
potential
so you have to expect it just to suck
and again by it's sucking by getting a
sucky result
it actually means that you're amazing
doesn't mean that you suck as a human
you only suck as a human is if you don't
try
to reward yourself for trying
search reward yourself for the effort
so to reward yourself for doing the
things that are outside your comfort
zone that are scary for you scary
difficult hard right you think of that
you're doing it and then you reward
yourself saying man I did that I can't
believe I did that was crazy
even though it didn't work out because
you know that if you kept trying and
kept learning and kept improving
that it of course is going to work out
you just have to show up with that level
of energy and enthusiasm and intent
every day
the difference between where you are
right now where you want to be is how
many experiments you're putting out
there
how many ideas that you've got that
you're trying
because you will not be rewarded for the
ideas that stay stuck in your head more
importantly you don't want to get to the
end of your life and look back and say I
had all these ideas but I was too afraid
of failing that I never tried any of
them
Wayne Dyer says don't let that song Die
within you
got to play the song while you're alive
you've got a great song in you
let's get it out to the World YouTube
has the best data platform of all of all
the social media networks and um I love
the data and I can geek out on it all
day long and dive into it it's
overwhelming for a lot of people the
only thing you have to care about is
this the audience retention curve like
write that down if you don't know what
I'm talking about and you think you
might at some day want to start a
YouTube channel come back to that write
it down it is your golden ticket the
audience retention curve what that does
is show you second by second where
people are either falling off your video
or sticking around second by second so
if your intros are really bad it'll show
you you lost half your audience in the
first 20 seconds cool like let's not do
that again and it'll show you these
little flat moments and a flat moment
means you never lost anybody like
whatever you did in that moment was
really good right you held their
attention that whole time think of it
like if you ever watch those elections
and uh the election debates and there's
like the red and the blue in America
right and you you like which who are you
liking more and they've got these people
in the audience who are kind of neutral
people or supposedly neutral and they're
like they're as the person's talking you
see the Blue Line go up where the red
line go up it's kind of like that on
your videos and it's completely free you
don't have to pay for any service or
anything else it's built into YouTube
natively in their analytics so when it's
a flat line when it's a downline then
okay that sucks we need to fix that
don't do that again but a flat moment is
good flat moment is good that means
you've kept their attention so if you
have a flat moment that's 40 seconds
long cool what happened there let's turn
that into a tweet let's turn it into an
Instagram reel let's turn them into
something else and then you have these
rare moments these special moments where
it goes up
well how does it go up like we lost
people we understand why it goes down
but how do we gain people in the middle
of the video it doesn't make sense right
because most people drop off like in the
first few seconds or whatever minutes is
the big fall off but then you it doesn't
just go down there's these spikes yeah
so why does it Spike like how does that
make sense that new people join the
video halfway through right usually not
usually what the case is is the people
who are currently watching rewound that
video to watch that part again it's like
what did Rory just say what was that
thing again and they rewinded to watch
that part again that's your goal and
that may be 20 minutes inside of your
video but that's what we cut and one we
want to make more content like that like
that can educate you to make better
content but then that also that's what
we cut so the flat moments are the
spikes that's what we cut to take to our
other social media accounts because we
know that that's popping and a lot of
people who are making content whether
they're doing it themselves or they have
Team there's a lot of subjective
decisions that go away it's like well I
like that part and I like the this
moment I think we should do here and
there's a lot of wasted time to be
honest and going back and reviewing and
watching the footage again and then
relying on one person's subjective
opinion to make the call on what goes to
the platforms to make your your diamond
um the data will show you it's a lot
easier just look at where we help people
on the video and let's take that to our
other platforms well to get great at
anything you have to be consistent or
anything any skill that you want to
develop you have to be consistent on at
the beginning of a journey it's okay to
experiment and taste and test and try
and do a bunch of things you know I made
my first video and I wasn't like the
next day making another video and the
next day making another video or it
wasn't consistent at the beginning and
my growth reflected it you know in year
one I post on my website where I'm at
with subscriber count year by year by
year and year one is like 25 subscribers
and by year five in my fifth year I'm
still at 700 something subscribers it's
not like I took off and was blowing up
right away a lot of it was me sucking
and not having the skill but a lot of it
was just lack of consistency as well and
that I wasn't doing it every day there's
a reason why AI from all the people I've
studied the number one rule for Success
that they have is you have to love what
you do not just the end result of the
thing that you're doing but you have to
love the actual thing that you're doing
it just takes so much effort and so much
time to get world class at the thing
that if you don't love it you're gonna
quit you kind of have to be crazy doing
it because you just love it so much for
most people with quit that's how you end
up winning and so finding the thing that
you love to do that you can stay
consistent on so that doesn't feel like
work is the thing that ends up getting
you through it like if you're hosting a
podcast show like this and you don't
like interviewing people do something
else don't do it because podcasting is a
hot Trend go do something else that you
really love to do we've made over 13 000
videos now in 13 years I've made videos
through tragedy and Trauma and the
broken neck and videos still went out
why because I love what I'm doing and
that's how I wasn't burning out and if I
stop liking making videos then I'll move
on to something else so the consistency
really matters but it's a lot easier to
stay consistent on the thing that you
actually love doing a lot of people
don't believe that I'm an introvert and
that I'm shy because of the work that I
do and it's uh I struggled a lot with it
Eric like if you look at the growth of
my YouTube channel at the beginning it
was so slow uh mostly because I was I
thought hey if you're going to talk
about yourself you have to have a huge
ego and you have to be a a blabbermouth
and just it wasn't me it's not how I
wanted to win uh and then I realized
well I I still want to serve like how do
I I still want to help how do I help and
once I could marry oh when I if I share
my story that actually can serve people
then it got me more and more comfortable
and I would never have said yes to this
like what why does he want to talk to me
it's crazy no I'm not coming on Eric's
show just because I would be nothing
nothing about you more I'm just too
afraid and too nervous and too shy like
I don't want to talk to people
um
I do a lot of my best creative work you
know when I'm by myself I actually have
no need to as long as I have my wife I'm
pretty good you know like I don't really
have a huge connection need but I want
to serve I don't want to feel like what
I'm doing matters and is important so I
can get really excited about a few
things right like if we're talking about
impact and Entrepreneurship or if you
want to dive into salsa dancing or
League of Legends I can get pretty
excited but anything else you know I I
no interest small talk you know how
about how about that local hockey team
or weather like I don't it just is not
interesting to me and I think that's one
of the things with with introverts is we
we want to have meaningful conversations
we're actually okay to have
conversations but we're better in small
groups or one-on-ones and we want to
have meaningful conversations and we
hate the small talk and what do you do
and
um just the the yeah just the small talk
is just not fun
um I remember I was on a flight I was
going from
Toronto to Puerto Rico I was speaking at
Brendan burchard's event in Puerto Rico
for his high-end Mastermind group and um
there was a guy next to me and uh he was
trying to start up all these
conversations they're like just I I
don't I just don't I don't I don't I
don't enjoy it
but I remembered everything about him I
remember you know the backpack that he
had and then he wanted a coffee once we
got into the air and he wanted a black
and you know I remembered all the all
the things about him but I just I don't
like the small talk conversation
um and then we got there and I took the
cab and got to the hotel and then in
behind me walks the same guy he was
going to the same event in Puerto Rico
and uh as soon as I saw him there he's
like oh dude you're an entrepreneur like
what do you do
as soon as I got into a you know service
and Entrepreneurship then instantly
became friends
um but just small talk is not as and
maybe that's the limitation to me or
something I need to work on
um but
the most important part of that was
realizing hey I need to get out there
because I want to serve and I want to
help in me not sharing my stories
actually selfish like we've all been
through something and there are other
people who are struggling right now with
the thing that you used to struggle with
if you think back to who you were 10
years ago and how much you were
struggling and just a difference in
mindsets and belief systems compared to
who you are now there's a lot of people
who are still stuck at who you were 10
years ago and they need help and they
don't know who to go to and they can't
connect to some of the big names out
there but they can connect to you
because you know exactly what they've
been through and you can you can help
that person and just sharing your story
is valuable and in you being silent it
perpetuates a silence for others and in
you sharing it and expressing yourself
to you know to your word uh it
encourages other people to express
themselves too it gives them permission
to express themselves too they may not
look to me and say the is possible for
them but they can look at you Eric and
say well Eric can do it he's like me he
went through the same things as I did if
he can do it then maybe I can too and
you sharing your story and expressing
yourself gives them permission to take
the step and start on their Journey as
well which is the greatest thing of all
time so even though
you know we're introverts you still want
to help still want to serve still want
to feel like what we do matters every
day you are what you consistently think
about whether you think you'll win or
lose you're right it's a challenge I
think a lot of us face we are stuck in
our head in our mind telling ourselves
why we can't do something why we're not
good enough we're born in the wrong
country we have the wrong skin color
we're the wrong gender we had the wrong
family we have the wrong education and
we just keep replaying these same
stories over and over and over and over
and over again and you don't win because
you believe that you can't win that's
what the great rewiring has to take
place inside all of us because that's
why I think that lack of belief is the
world's number one problem I'm on a
mission to solve the world's number one
problem people do not believe in
themselves to create amazing things I
think everybody has Michael Jordan level
genius at something that you are the
greatest in the world at something and
it's probably not what you went to
school for and it's probably not what
your parents did for a living it's
something totally different and a
challenge in being able to go and Chase
down something that's totally different
is the belief that it's possible
because when you are around people who
are not living their life who are
complaining who are negative who may not
be toxic but who are stuck
people who are stuck
the easiest thing to do is to get stuck
yourself and to have the thought
patterns that keep you stuck this is why
I create all my channels
because I need it for me because I want
to be around people who challenge me who
when I see what they're doing it forces
me to think different to think bigger to
want to do more to want to be a better
Evan Carmichael whatever that means
right to just feel like I'm I want to
grow and do more because I'm around the
people who are doing that
where if you stay stuck with the people
that you're in right now you stay stuck
in the environment that you're
participating in right now then you will
likely stay there and not grow and not
improve and not learn and not get better
now
that doesn't mean that you stop caring
it doesn't mean that you stop giving it
doesn't mean that you stop contributing
it in fact it's the opposite
you if you're watching this video you're
on a journey you're on a growth curve
and you want to go here right you want
to climb you want to get better you're
you're you want to go over there and
there may be people who are who are even
pulling you back actively saying not to
do that don't do that you can't do that
the goal isn't even necessarily to leave
these people behind
the goal could be to come back and help
them
but how can you help them and how can
you pour even more into them well by
learning more and improving yourself
more that every time that you learn
something and you get better at
something you can come back and pour it
into other people that when you're
taking your growth curve you're stepping
your climbing you're improving you're
getting better every step that you take
you know if you now you move to step
number four you can help others other
people get to step number three you can
reach back and help them climb up
another step
so it doesn't mean that you stop being
optimistic and positive and helpful for
the people around you that's that's your
light that's your gift that's what you
are so amazing at
but it does mean that you need to
inject newness into your environment
because your environment is crafting
your thoughts and your thoughts are
keeping you stuck
you might have these moments where you
feel bold and brave and you can do
something else but
those aren't consistent and because the
boldness in thought is not consistent
the boldness and action is not
consistent and so you stay stuck doing
the same thing knowing that you're
capable of more we're not doing the
thing and this is a game for everybody
this is this is for myself this is for
you this is for the people who are ahead
of you on their growth curve you never
want to stop there's always a new level
of of self-talk and self-belief to get
you to the next thing that's possible
so it's why I do what I do because I
need it for me I need to be around
people who inspire me every day so that
I can continue to organize for kindness
right Martin Luther King had a great
quote about organizing for kindness that
people organized for negativity to
organize uh looting and the organized
violence and their organized Wars and
their organized negativity well who's
organizing for kindness right that's
what we need to do but you need to have
the inspired environment to create the
inspired thoughts to allow the inspired
action to come out so you can organize
for kindness too
so let's break down how do you actually
start doing it how do you actually start
to change that self-talk to be a more
positive one so that you can actually
follow through on the great ideas that
you have for yourself
number one
is to be around your Heroes who are your
Heroes who have done the thing that you
love doing either the actual work itself
like they're in your industry and they
have done the thing if you know my story
you know I looked up to Bill Gates he
had a software company I had a software
company I learned from him to build my
company I haven't met him but yet but uh
his strategy save my company and then I
also learned from someone like Oprah
Winfrey or Kanye West or people who are
not in my industry but I just like for
some reason I'm gonna go and learn from
them so who are your Heroes either in
your industry or people that you just
look up to for some reason
and force yourself to spend more time
with them
be around them more put their pictures
up on the wall behind you my favorite
entrepreneur of all time is AP giannini
who started Bank of America put their
pictures on the wall behind you
subscribe to their YouTube channels if
they have it follow them on social media
read their books listen to their
podcasts like have them be in your
environment as much as possible because
they will transport you to another world
they will help you change that self-talk
in your head because the people who have
done the thing that you want to do your
Heroes the people you look up to likely
have done it with less than what you
have right now
the the resources that you have right
now the heart that you have right now
the the mental capacity that you have
right now the tools at your disposal you
know you have the internet you've got a
lot of tools at your disposal get a lot
of Technology at your disposal that your
Heroes didn't have as much access to if
any and they went off and won
so yes it might be difficult but if they
can do it you can do it too the question
is who you're going to listen to you
know the voice that says it's too hard
I'm never going to do it or the voice
that says well they can do it I can do
it too
so you have to be around you want to
change that self-talk you have to be
around your mentors Your Heroes because
they will pull you to a different place
set number two is to create a calendar
that has your habits in there your goals
that you've set for yourself needs to be
reflected in the habits because goals
don't accomplish themselves goals will
happen when you put time on your
calendar to go and make it happen I'm
making this video because it's in my
calendar this block of time right now to
go make videos right what do you need to
put in your calendar so that it's not
just a hope a dream a goal but it
actually becomes something that's in
reality and then to start to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your own calendar you want to start
to change yourself belief yourself talk
your that voice inside your head you
have to teach yourself that you follow
through on the things that you say
you're gonna do have fewer goals have
fewer things that you write down in your
calendar
but when they're in there they get done
because here's what happens every time
you set a goal every time you put
something in your calendar and you don't
do it you're training yourself that the
next time you put something in your
calendar that's not going to get done
too you're losing credibility with
yourself not even somebody else saying
you can't do it it's you your own voice
saying you can't do it because you
haven't done the last thing that you
said you were going to do or the thing
before that
so the rate is start to rewire that is
to when you put something in your
calendar it's going to get done to even
lower the barrier lower the standard for
what has to get done for you to get the
check mark that you accomplished this
thing that when it gets put in your
calendar you are going to be the person
who actually follows through that starts
to shift identity
that starts to help you believe more in
yourself that the next thing that you
add in your calendar you're also going
to get done
so how do we start to change that
self-talk right that criticism or or
compassionate voice in our head how do
we how do we shift towards belief one be
around our mentors and our heroes the
people who Inspire us to do it two
create a calendar that reflects our
goals our actions have to map to our
Ambitions right has to be in your
calendar and teach yourself that you do
the things that are in your calendar and
step number three would be to collect
good people
I'm a huge fan of collecting good people
if you believe like I believe that your
environment is keeping you stuck and
keeping you where you are
okay a shift can be to be around your
Heroes but you never you may never meet
them
good people when you're around the right
people
who fill you up as opposed to you
filling others up all the time it
changes everything you're a giver you're
caring you've got a big heart it's why
you're part of this community I love you
for that and keep going keep doing it
don't stop pointing to others
but who's pointing to you
when you walk away from a conversation
how often do you feel better about
yourself how often you have more energy
as opposed to well that was draining to
me you need to start to inject the
people who make you feel better who give
you more energy
and you may know some of them they may
not be the closest of friends to you yet
but whenever you meet somebody if it's
at an event or a conference or group or
in the comments section or on a Discord
and they just make you feel better
fight to try to find a way to spend more
time with them the way I'll often do it
is through businesses I end up setting
companies with them because I love them
so much it's a way to spend more time
with them
but it can be awkward at the beginning
like you don't know what you're gonna do
but you'll be the person to reach out to
say hey I'd love to have a coffee with
you next week or maybe we can schedule a
a monthly Mastermind with us and maybe a
couple other people like you reach out
to find a way to collect good people and
fight to spend more time with them
because when you're around actual humans
who are in front of you who make you
feel better about yourself and give you
the energy that you're pouring in other
people
it gives you more hope more momentum and
increases the chances of you actually
following through so get into the
practice of collecting good people
lack of belief is the single biggest
problem in the world you
have Michael Jordan level genie says
something you are the greatest in the
world at something
it's just your belief my belief too and
the ability to actually go and Chase it
down that will make the difference
between the life that you have right now
and the life that you know you're
capable of living let's solve that
together this is where my perfectionist
nature you know used to take over and
slow me down so I could get an idea and
you get these ideas and then your brain
takes over and you start researching
like I gotta I gotta make the perfect
Plan before I start don't make any
mistakes so I'm just going to start what
I've trained myself to do
is two things one
I tell myself that great ideas flow
through me
that great ideas will flow through me
because it came through me then it's a
great idea and what that does is kind of
shortcut the brain from over analyzing
over preparing and overthinking that as
long as you're in a good emotional state
right I feel like if you're frustrated
or pissed off or upset or jealous maybe
don't trust the ideas that come to you
you know like if somebody cuts you off
in line or in traffic and you want to go
chasing like maybe think on that one but
but if you're in a and if you're in a
positive place if you're watching this
episode and you feel inspired or hopeful
or or you want to do more you're
grateful trust the ideas that come to
you because those ideas often don't make
sense like your next great idea doesn't
make sense
because your brain tries to make sense
of it but it doesn't make sense but your
heart wants to do it so it's it's
listening to your heart and just
trusting that great ideas flow through
you from there to get over the
perfectionism uh I would I came up with
what I call a two percent difference so
what most people do is focus on how do I
plan to 100 I'm going to start a podcast
so I need to have look at Alan's setup
he's got the TVs and he's got the
microphone and he's got the right and
people would look at that I need all
that before I start the two percent
difference is if you trust a great ideas
flow through you then what's the first
two percent
what's the first two percent that you
can do right now just to get started and
don't expect it to be perfect expect it
to suck but momentum for most people is
the only thing that's missing
we often use our best energy on planning
and so you come up with an idea and then
you're planning you planning you plan
and plan your strategies and then a week
goes by I know you realize you don't
have the same courage and boldness that
you had a week ago and you spend all of
that great energy on planning instead of
doing where the first step should be to
do something
and then you start working on the plan
so if you want to work out you got to
get healthy or cool what's the perfect
workout plan well did you do hit do you
do cardio do you hire trainer you you go
to the gym and lift weights like what
are you gonna do there's so many options
the best thing to do is just do as many
push-ups as you can right now right you
get on the floor and you do five
push-ups 20 push-ups like however many
you can do is that going to help you
long term get your result no it's just
one day of doing a thing but the it
solves the most important problem which
is momentum because if you do 10
push-ups today then you can do 12
tomorrow you can do 14 the next day you
could do 20 the next day and then as you
start applying maybe you realize hey
push-ups aren't the thing maybe you
should be doing pull-ups maybe you
should be doing yoga maybe right like
the plan always changes just like we
talked about the island from five years
ago could not plan to where the Allen is
right now the plan will always change
but the biggest thing is missing for
most people is just momentum so trust
that great ideas flow through you and
then apply the two percent difference to
just get started and the only thing
you're missing is momentum this is one
of the most frustrating things with
entrepreneurs because you've got the
heart you've got the soul you've got the
desire to serve you know you're capable
of more you see these people doing great
things you say why why can't that be me
I've got everything I've got all the
tools why am I not having more success
when I see all these other people
winning because you don't have momentum
knowing alone is not enough watching
this video is not enough researching
going to conferences events it's not
enough it gives us this temporary high
it's so fun to think about where we
could be and what we could do when
living in dream mode of the things that
we want to create how That's so exciting
right but until you start actually doing
something and so you start going through
that little fear Zone to start actually
creating nothing happens and this is one
of the great missions of my life is
trying to get heart-centered
entrepreneurs with a cause you want to
serve and just getting you out of the
Starting Gate and then just help when
you stay consistent on the thing those
two things from idea to just doing
something and then finding a way to stay
consistent if you did that if you did
that's all you're missing if you did
that your life will be dramatically
different the people you're going to
serve the the amount of income you're
going to make the life you can provide
for yourself and your family the the
mass massive just flow of goodness
you're going to create for the world
will be totally different you will be a
totally different person when you're
from today if you did those simple
things the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum I promise you
I look at
my YouTube channel and everything that
we've done here and man it took me so
long to get going it took me so long to
get out of my head it took me so long to
get comfortable making videos no matter
how much people told me just press
record and just do it it's still it's
still that voice inside my head is like
well I'm so awkward in front of the
camera and I don't know what I'm gonna
say and I'm trying to memorize my script
and what camera should I find and all of
the things that we tell ourselves are
important that aren't
growth on YouTube the first five years
was so slow the first five years was so
incredibly slow because I started and
stopped and started and stopped and
started and stopped and convinced myself
of why I couldn't do it and my whole
intent with this is to try to shake you
to say don't waste five years like I did
because in the second five years that's
when my channel started to really blow
up and grow and that's when I started to
see the impact and see the growth and
see the see the the money coming in all
of it it started to take off because I
just started creating a lot more
momentum I stopped watching my videos
and reminding myself of how much I
sucked and just kept going
so how do you do it how do you start
building momentum how do you start
taking the thing that you know is inside
you that you know you're capable of more
that you don't want to be stuck in the
same spot one year from today it's like
I need to finally make something happen
right is that you are you ready for that
how do we actually start getting the
momentum in our lives I'm going to give
you three strategies okay
number one
your morning routine has to be on point
as I said on top of this video
successful people don't wake up and say
yes oh my gosh what a day I'm gonna take
over this is gonna be amazing I woke up
and I was tired I don't remember what
day it is and I got lines in my face and
I'm struggling out of bed right
everybody wakes up the same way
don't judge yourself and feel like you
suck because you woke up and you were
tired and didn't feel super motivated to
go off and crush your day right that's
everybody that's me that's Brandon
burchard That's Tony Robbins it's Oprah
Winfrey everybody the difference is the
routine to set you up for success and
chances are if you watch this video you
already have a morning routine right
you're an achiever you have a morning
routine so I want to take this to the
next level for people with a morning
routine because your morning routine is
probably not working for you most of the
world doesn't have a morning routine
most of the world wakes up like an
accident most of the world wakes up
falls into their phone and starts
responding to other people's emergencies
right that's probably not you at least
not every day you might be 50 50 but you
probably have a morning routine
what's the value of a morning routine
the value of a morning routine
is to get you the feeling of bold
confidence and courage
that's why you have more routine it's
supposed to help you go and win the day
if you don't feel confident bold and
courage at the end of your morning
routine then you've done something wrong
either the morning routine itself is
broken and you need to add something in
or you just didn't do it with enough
intent
most Achievers here's what's happening I
want you to do a fair self-assessment
and audit of your morning routine most
Achievers what you're doing is you have
your list of things that you're supposed
to do in the morning and you probably
hit those maybe 70 to 80 of the time
but most of the time of those 70 80 you
just check in the box
you said you're gonna do this okay I'm
gonna work out I'm gonna watch this
video I'm gonna read this book and
listen to this podcast so I'm going to
whatever but you're not intentional with
it having this video on was I created
the espresso channel here to try to
support you to try to be there for your
morning routine to give you a shot of
espresso every day to start your day
let's go but if you're watching this
video while you're making your bed and
brushing your teeth and and looking over
your email and browsing through social
media guess what happens
you're not getting the feeling
you could check the box and say yep
watch the video but if you don't feel
courageous and bold
you didn't do it with enough intent you
didn't do it with enough Focus you were
distracted all the way through and so
this is what happens with Achievers in
the morning routine is you check the box
for all the things you said you were
gonna do but you don't feel any better
than you did when you woke up
and if you don't feel any better than
you did when you woke up you're not
going to go off and win the day so the
most important part of a morning routine
whether it takes you five minutes or
three hours
is getting the feeling so do an honest
self-assessment
do you feel bold at the end of your
morning routine and if not what you need
to add in there so that you do
or do you need to go back and just do
your morning routine with actual
intention because if you'd started your
day with the thing that made you feel
bold powerful Unstoppable confident your
life will dramatically change when
you're from today I promise you so
number one is you have to fix in one
routine
number two to get more momentums how do
we get more momentum in our lives number
two
is to go from idea to action
start to teach yourself that you come up
with great ideas normally what happens
when you get an idea what happens
normally when you get an idea
we get excited maybe you tell your
friends about it your family or you're
just researching and planning and
brainstorming you get excited about it
and then what happens is this little
voice inside your head tells you all the
reasons why you can't do it you can't do
it because of this because of that
because you don't have the connections
the money the skills or the education
the family or whatever there's always
some reason and so the combat that you
try to do more research and more
planning and more more understanding to
try to have the perfect plan and this
was me guys I lost a 40 million deal
when I was in my 20s because I was
trying to be too perfect because I was
afraid and all I really need to do is
get more momentum so you have to teach
yourself to go from idea to action when
you get that idea
trust that the idea came to you for a
reason trust that the intention is good
is the intention good is the intention
to serve is the intention to help yes
perfect action something today has to
happen today use your best energy on
creating some kind of momentum in
Perfect action versus trying to have the
perfect plan
and then you wake up tomorrow and you've
already talked yourself down you can't
do it so number one is you have to fix
your morning routine
number two is you have to go from idea
to action and then number three is to
change your environment
the more that you are around the people
who are doing the thing that you want to
do the more that that starts to seep
into YouTube
it's why I have so many channels because
there's always content hopefully out
there for you you might say yeah but I
don't know anybody Evan who's successful
I I can't hang out with Brandon burchard
or Oprah or whoever I don't know these
people great
I know Brandon but I know I don't know
Oprah
and I didn't know Brandon when I first
got started how did I learn from the
videos about having videos around me
every day having these people on the
wall behind me even wearing this hoodie
when I feel like Batman putting it on
every morning makes a big difference to
start to change your environment to be
around the people who are thinking the
way that you want to think the people
around you right now are influencing you
to stay where you are
might think about the people who you
hang out with now that old expression of
you are the average of the five closest
people to you yeah great so who are the
five closest people to you they are
influencing your thinking and they're
keeping you stuck where you are right
now and if you love where you are right
now great but if you know you want to do
more then you have to start to change
what starts to influence you
consistently not these one-off moments
of inspiration and boldness but
consistency that's the thing that's
missing you might have this one day it's
amazing oh my gosh I can do anything and
what happens you wake up tomorrow and
all that energy is gone it's a start and
stop and start and stop and start and
stop that is holding you back
so be strategic with your environment to
think about how do I start to surround
myself with the people with the videos
with the books with the podcast with the
physical environment that make me feel
like I can do more that you can do more
fix those three things fix your morning
routine go for my day to action and fix
your environment do that because the
only thing you're missing is momentum
the only thing you have you have the
heart you have the care you have the
desire to serve you have great ideas
inside you
other people are winning with inferior
ideas with less of a desire to serve
than you do and they're winning and the
only difference is they got started and
they're going
the only thing you're missing is
momentum
I can't wait to see you actually start
to apply it to make massive change in
your life and your business I'm a visual
learner I like to be able to see stuff
so I don't listen to any podcast I'm on
a bunch of podcasts but Audio Only is
the is the hardest way for me to learn
this is a podcast but the fact that I
can see you helps because otherwise I'd
be like I'd be closing my eyes it'd be
covering my ears because it's really
it's just the hardest way for me to
learn Audio Only
when I started in 2009 on YouTube uh it
was the only video platform so it wasn't
that I knew it was going to be huge like
nobody had a million subscribers being a
YouTuber wasn't even a thing I was
making six minute videos and people were
telling me that it was way too long and
I didn't understand how the internet
worked and all of this stuff yeah uh so
I mean it's come a long way since 2009
but it was just the only visual place at
the time and I I wanted to I wanted to
share so
most of the stuff was either my own what
I had learned or what I had learned from
Steve Jobs or Oprah Winfrey or Kanye
West or whoever and sharing their
lessons with the world because that's
what really saved my company and I
thought like you know 50 people watched
a video maybe that changes somebody's
life it was never designed like now
there's a whole there's a whole business
model around it right like you could
create entire Mega corporations around
it and people are going to YouTube to
learn you know it's the education
platform now
so it was very different when I got
started it was just I want to tell
stories I want to help people and and I
like video because it's a visual
platform if you're getting started now
and you're trying to figure out where
should I be
the strength of YouTube is that it's the
only long form
video platform around right so if you're
gonna do if you do a video podcast we're
gonna host it you're not going to post a
hour it's so it's YouTube and YouTube is
now the educational place the people
default to so if somebody's trying to
figure out how to make a big shift in
their life where are they going to go
are they going to the library you know
are they going to talk to their mom like
they're going to YouTube and there's
like how do I make a shift and there's
Anthony trucks it's like I've never
heard of this guy but he's got awesome
message right and then that's how you
start to bring on new people and build
your movement up all of the other
platforms are still great
but they'd lean in more on the
inspirational side so Instagram Tick
Tock it's great you know you can give
you have a minute to say something
really fantastic and it's just hoping to
plant a seed with people but you're not
really making a shift in a minute long
video for people and so where short form
goes there's lots of different options
there's no there's no
bunch of people tried to come up make
the YouTube killer there's no YouTube
killer out yet but who knows in 10 years
we're going to be doing this in VR I'm
going to be holograming into your room
you know look at the technology will
change but right now if you are an
expert if you're a thought leader and
that's all I focus on right I'm not the
YouTube guy for like slime channels or
makeup tutorials or whatever it's like
education thought leadership
entrepreneurship personal development
that's where I live
um YouTube needs to be your number one
home I think everybody has the single
most important core value
and when you figure out what that is it
allows you to live a more intentional
life so like even if you had to pick
what's your most important core value oh
man Integrity it's a big one just being
a green period
uh I mean I mean that makes sense
knowing you and so now when you're
looking at you know who do I whether
it's in a relationship with somebody or
you're bringing on team if you're gonna
if you're gonna bring on a new video
editor for your team what most people do
is just think do they have the skills
that I need where for you that's not
enough they have to they have to be a
person of Integrity big time and when
you're around people of Integrity it
just allows everything to to flow more
right where you had the greatest video
editor of all time but they're they're
cutting Corners in line or whatever it's
not just about the results like how they
get it really matters to you and so it
changes the intention with which you
show up so if you're going to do a job
posting now for a video editor it's like
you post a video editor who believes in
Integrity like and that's the title and
some people will see that and say that's
the stupidest thing of all time who is
this guy like cool like don't apply
right like
self-eliminate thank you and others
would be like yes finally somebody's
speaking my language and so I think
everybody has a single most important
core value and it's at the job of
finding out what that is for you and so
for me it's believe and
that becomes the brand and that like
your brain is just an emotion so I want
people to leave everything that I make
with more belief uh I may not accomplish
it uh but it's the intention in
everything that I make and so if you
could gift Integrity To The World what a
great what a great gift to be able to
create I like it
um
people don't show up for one of three
reasons number one is you're afraid
you're afraid of rejection you're afraid
of failure you're afraid of it not
working out and so you just don't show
up number two is you're not consistent
you show up some days but you don't show
up other days because you don't have the
routines and habits in place to make you
show up consistently every single day
and number three is you don't want to
you don't want to show up because you
don't actually enjoy the thing that
you're about to do you would rather
procrastinate on it because you don't
love it and showing up is more painful
than just sitting around so my goal
today with this video is to help you
bust through these so that you can show
up for life and have the impact that you
want to have so I think the fear of
showing up is actually a good thing it
means that you are doing something
different something outside your comfort
zone something that is that is not
normal that is new and that's good you
want to be pushing the envelope if there
was nothing that you were afraid to show
up to today tomorrow next week then
you're not growing you're not learning
you're not pushing against your
boundaries and Company zones and so even
today I had to show up but and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel more across pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed for the people with a new idea
that I had so when the idea was first
suggested to me about doing us and
reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay
it's gonna require an ask I might get
rejected it may not work out and I had
it scheduled for today because today was
my YouTube day and so I look at the list
today and like ah maybe I should start
with one person or two people or just
pick the easy people and just the fact
that I felt that just the fact that that
was one of the reasons meant I had to go
and do five I had to do a bigger number
I had to go after the harder people I
had to do the people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
gonna care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just train in yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid so I'm
going to give you a three-step process
you can follow to help you conquer your
fears to help you show up consistently
every day let's do it number one is tell
yourself that you do scary things one of
the biggest reasons why people don't
Advance their ideas forward is because
it's scary it's scary you're afraid
amazing that is now no longer an
acceptable reason you do scary things
you love scary things you Embrace scary
things you want to do scary things
this isn't just a mindset trick it's
actually true you want to do scary
things you do what's the opposite of
scary things the opposite of scare if
you walk through life and you're never
scared of anything it's not that you're
super confident no it means that you're
living inside your comfort zone it means
you're only doing things that have zero
fear that you have absolute certainty in
because you've done it before
you're bored you're living inside your
bubble and you need to break out because
that means you're photocopying your life
every single day if there's nothing in
your calendar that makes you scared you
hate your life and so pay attention to
the language pay attention to how you
talk to yourself pay attention to when
you feel afraid and as long as it's not
against your code of ethics or doing
something stupid don't go jump out of an
airplane without a parachute because
you're afraid
right most of the things you're afraid
of are not life-threatening
teach yourself that you do scary things
you love scary things and you're not
allowed to use as an excuse anymore for
not taking action number two is think
what makes you sore what is the thing
that gets you feeling bold alive
confident ready to take action wanting
to show up to life what is it I go
through five s's every morning as part
of my morning routine the versus sing
and then sun and then soar and then
sweat and then scare the most important
part is sore though it's a thing that I
do to make me come alive that makes me
want to soar and so for me what I do is
I think about an entrepreneur that I
helped yesterday and then I pull up my
phone and then I record a message and I
share that to my YouTube stories
Instagram stories Twitter LinkedIn I put
it everywhere
I need to feel like the work that I do
matters right now I'm just talking to a
camera I'm just talking into a camera
right now and and later it's gonna be
edited and it's gonna be thrown up on
YouTube and lots of people are going to
watch the video that's that's crazy it's
hard to imagine because I'm just sitting
here in my office talking into a camera
and so I need to remember that the work
I do has purpose that this matters to
some people right that people rely on my
videos every day as a part of their
routine
and that helps make me sore so I wake up
just like everybody else I'm tired I'm I
don't know what time it is sometimes
even this morning I woke up I didn't
even know what day it was is it the
weekend is it I had no idea right yeah
wake up I'm not coming out of the day
scene yeah oh my gosh let's go right
that's not how anybody wakes up nobody
that's not how Grant Cardone wakes up
Evan Carmichael Tony Robbins no but it's
not how we wake up the difference is the
habits that you set on a daily basis to
demand that success to demand that you
show up
and so what is the thing that helps make
you soar maybe it's remembering the
impact you want to have maybe it's
sharing a message to YouTube to
Instagram to LinkedIn maybe it's doing
an active service maybe it's meditation
maybe it's reading maybe it's watching
these videos what is it that makes you
feel like you want to soar and then
don't randomly hope that it happens the
man that is part of your morning routine
because if you woke up and did the thing
to make you sore to make you feel bold
confident Unstoppable and you did that
every day for the next year your life
will be dramatically different you will
not recognize the person who you used to
be
the challenge is you're not consistent
in soaring and so I need you to make
that part of your morning routine and
then number three is understand what is
your Michael Jordan Talent what could
you be the greatest in the world at you
could be the
the greatest of all time at something
you are but what is that thing most
people are living way below the
potential because they settled you
settled too early you settled because
you were pressured you settled because
you were afraid you settled because you
ran out of time or at least you felt you
did that's not an acceptable answer
anymore you could be the greatest in the
world at something and if you're
procrastinating on something it's either
because you're afraid of the thing in
which case you need to go and do it
because you do scary you do afraid right
back to tip number one or two you just
don't like it you procrastinate because
you don't like it and if you continue to
do work that you don't like you're never
going to be the best
because you're going up against people
who love it who love it
who love it
right if you're going up to play
basketball against Michael Jordan you
better love the game as much as he does
or you're gonna lose if it's just a
strategy for you you're gonna lose and
so look at the thing that's in front of
you look at the thing that you are not
showing up for it's for one of those
three reasons either you're afraid to do
it and therefore you must do it or two
you don't have consistent habits in
which case you need to put the thing
that makes you soar into your morning
routine or three you just don't actually
want to do it and stop forcing yourself
to do it go off and find the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
the fastest way to figure out what to do
just a model success model success
whenever you don't know what to do model
success
what that does is when you can find
somebody who's done the thing that you
want to do right like they think about
what are your goals what do you want to
accomplish what do you want to what do
you want to do in life right in life and
business what do you want to do what do
you want to accomplish where do you want
to go find people who've done it
and and the key thing is don't look at
what they're doing right now because
that's not going to be very helpful for
you instead what we want to do is look
at what do they do when they started
how do they go from zero to one how do
they get their thing off the ground
because it it does it does two key
things it gives you hope that it's
possible whenever you look at your
Heroes mentors people who've done
amazing things we often feel when we
look at our goals that it's not possible
because that happened to you you look at
your goals your big goals not not your
little ones but the big goals like
that's not possible I can't do that
sometimes you feel like you can and it's
inspiring like yes I can't wait to do
that and other times it feels like the
big gold is too big and you're never
gonna be able to do that right is that
does that sound familiar so then when
you're able to see people who have done
it it gives you the hope the motivation
the inspiration that you can do it too
and if you look at their store you'll
see that they probably started with less
than what you already have right now
chances are Your Heroes they started
with less than what you already have
right now
and if they could do it why can't you
because of the story that you're telling
yourself and so being around those
stories being around those people even
if it's
from from books and videos and podcasts
right being around that makes you
realize holy cow this is possible
the second thing it does is it gives you
strategies it's like well what did they
do not just the motivation to act but
what specifically to do how did they do
it how did they get started
this is what saved my business Bill
Gates like to say save my business I
haven't met Bill Gates yet but he saved
my business
because I had a software company
and I quit on my business partner
I didn't know what to do I didn't know
what to do next I was making no money
I'm making 300 bucks a month I'm
struggling I'm suffering I I'm trying
I'm working hard every day and I just I
don't know what to do I don't know what
to do I don't know what to do help me
please I tried everything everything
that I could think of and nothing seemed
to be working and I was tired of being
broke and tired of being tired and tired
of not having results I'm tired of
having sex I was just I was I was beaten
down
I was tired
I had to find a different way
and so I quited my business partner
which was the worst day of my life and
then I woke up the next day and said I
can't quit yet because if I do I'm gonna
regret it
but I can't keep going the way that I'm
going I have to find a different way to
stand and so I said you know what
somebody's figured this out somebody's
figured this out somebody had to figure
this out who's figured this out who's
built the software company
and the first person I could think it
was Bill Gates and Microsoft was then I
spent a ton of time researching and
understanding it's just I was desperate
I was hopeless I was lost and I just
thought Bill Gates Microsoft and so I
looked at how did Bill Gates start
Microsoft zero to one right how did it
get started how's somebody who's super
successful makes an extra million
dollars now or you know how I might get
an extra thousand subscribers now it's
not it's not as relevant it's not as
inspiring it's not as helpful because
there's a lot of momentum that goes into
it already so but zero to one how did he
get started
and I found out that he did it through
Partnerships
[Music]
found people who was already targeting
his target audience and he partnered
with them
partnership in terms of they owned a
part of Microsoft but they they made a
deal together
so Microsoft's big deal came with IBM
where every IBM IBM was the biggest
computer manufacturer at the time every
IBM computer shipped had Microsoft
software on it IBM had a new computer
they wanted to get it out to the market
they needed some great software for it
and operating system Microsoft came
along and helped them and so every IBM
ship had Microsoft software on it
like wow that's great and that blew up
the company that was like their giant
momentum moment but Microsoft is already
a seven million dollar company I think
when they made that deal
so how did they go from zero to seven
well same thing Partnerships their very
first partnership came with a company
called mitts they had this device called
the Altair and it was on the cover of um
of a magazine and Bill Gates and Paul
Allen his business partner saw it and
they said if mits is going to come up
with the Altair
they need software for it let's write to
them and say that we can we can do the
software
and uh they said okay cool yeah come on
I'd love to see your software now this
is a little maybe sneakier underhanded
Bill Gates had not written the software
for it yet he didn't even have his hands
on on one of the midsole tears he's
coding it without having a device and
without having it ready and luckily by
the time he gets to them in the meeting
it actually worked right so that's a lot
of risk and that's a lot of staking
reputation a guess on yourself and your
ability and hoping that it's going to
work out maybe a little too risky for me
but it was still the concept of
Partnerships who was already targeting
my target audience your target audience
and instead of trying to go after
customers one by one by one how can you
work with somebody who if they told
people about you it would reach 10
people at a time or 100 people at a time
or a thousand people at a time or a
million people at a time right how can
we make that happen
and so I looked to my own business like
okay we sell scientific software who
else sells scientific not software but
other products that I can make some kind
of partnership with and and the first
company that I connected with was in the
UK
and I messaged them to say hey we've got
this company we've got the software
do you want to represent us in Europe
and I forget which markets we looked at
but UK and a couple other countries do
you want to represent us in Europe
because our software is great it works
but we we you know the customer support
and language differences and time zone
differences would you like to be our
partner in the UK and they said yes how
do we get started
I was nervous I was sweating I was
trying to figure out oh my gosh I got my
first potential deal here I'm I'm how
old I'm 20 at the time ish
um
and I say okay there's an uh there's a
there's an upfront commitment of
Thirteen and a half thousand dollars
they had to pay us thirteen and a half
thousand dollars by the time I'm making
300 bucks a month so I guess that's kind
of my bold little my bold my bold
statement or my bold commitment like
Bill Gates so you got to pay me 13 and a
half thousand dollars up front and I I
remember pressing send on the email and
uh
sweating nervous I don't want to lose
this deal you know finally got somebody
at the table and I said yes
they said yes
crazy they said yes and and then the
money hit our bank account like oh my
gosh 13 half thousand dollars this is
crazy
it doesn't seem like a lot of money now
but man I felt like I won the lottery I
felt rich
and more important than just the money
was that something worked you know
momentum finally like something anything
was actually having an impact it's crazy
and uh I had a strategy that I could I
could apply I could go after other
companies and that's what I did like I
closed more and more and more deals more
of these partnership deals all based off
of Bill Gates's strategy right so again
I haven't met Bill Gates I haven't told
them this story yet
but the way that he built Microsoft
became an inspiration for me to build my
my company at least in the early days
and it got our company off the ground
and starting to get some results
and so one of you don't know what to do
you model success you find the person
who's done the thing it gives you hope
it gives you inspiration and it also
gives you specific strategies now it may
not fit a hundred percent right
I had to research Bill Gates I had to
see how he got started I had to see his
first deals and my idea wasn't exactly
the same deal that he signed but it's
close enough and all I really needed was
was the idea was a strategy to get
started and it saved my company saved my
business I mean I don't know if I didn't
do that I might have some job right now
that I hate honestly like I just quit on
my business partner
I was afraid I was going to live in
regret of not knowing
and
I was just lost guys I was just lost
but I knew that if I stopped now that I
I would look back on that moment and say
what if I just kept going
and if I didn't find that strategy I
don't know what I would have done
honestly probably at some job that I
hate
it's crazy how these little little
shifts little moments
can make such a giant difference in your
life and so hopefully this video can
help inspire a little moment for you
so if you surround yourself with your
Heroes you look at the people who are
doing the thing that you want to do and
be around them more and study their
success it gives you the hope and the
motivation that it's possible
and hopefully it also gives you the
specific strategies and what you can do
so you can accomplish your goals as well
the fastest way to build your business
to get the right ideas to grow is to
model success let's go here YouTube is
is an education platform like I think a
lot of people think of it as as
entertainment and fun and movies and
music cool but YouTube is is the number
one education platform so you know
people are trying to figure out how to
become a more influential leader where
are they going to go they're going to go
to the library yeah who are they going
to talk to they're going to talk to
their mom like what they're going to go
and search and your stuff will pop up
and not just your videos but against
other people's videos this content that
people are going there to learn and so
YouTube is different than every other
platform
where we want to be making long-form
content teaching people because ahead of
whatever we're trying to sell we want to
put information we want to put education
okay we're teaching people at scale to
then bring them into whatever the thing
is that we're selling coaching products
program Services books Etc and the
beauty of something like YouTube is one
your your content list forever so the
videos you make now in a year and two
years and six years are still getting
your views subscribers attention leads
Etc or every other platform it goes away
right like Instagram nobody cares what
you posted a week ago it's instant it's
Instagram it's gone every other
platform's the same YouTube has the best
monetization so they'll pay you right
like you could be making seven figures
just from the ad revenue on your videos
as well as actually building your
business
um and the best part about YouTube is
you can take the content since it's long
form and splice it up to put in all the
other platforms so YouTube will tell you
the best moments in every video
according to what the audience cared
about those little highlight moments you
can then tweak and put them to Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook and all the
other platforms so all you really have
to do is have a Regular Show long form
on YouTube and now we're creating
content everywhere most of the people
listening watching your goal is not to
be a full-time just content creator you
got a business that you're trying to run
we're trying to build our membership
groups and our coaching services and be
a speaker and all of that stuff and so
you don't have time to all day every day
be on every single platform you don't
have to be long form from YouTube take
the data cut it up to be on every
platform so it kind of sits above all
the other social media platforms and
most importantly to help people's
message get out to change the world hard
work is your ticket in
hard work doesn't guarantee your success
but it's your ticket in there's nobody
who you look up to who you respect who
you want to be like who did not work
incredibly hard to get to where they're
at now people say work smart work smart
work yes there's lots of people who work
hard and never get anywhere close to
their goals there's lots of people who
work incredibly hard who who stay
earning minimum wage their entire life
because they didn't work smart they were
only working hard but there's nobody who
just works smart and doesn't work hard
even if they're fooling you with their
pictures on Instagram it's that
combination of working hard plus working
smart I've covered
most of these people I've hung out with
a lot of these people I see the
incredible smarts that they have and the
activities that they choose but also
just the work ethic they have the show
up every day and stay consistent on
their goals
so in this video I'm gonna try to give
you some tips and steps on how to
actually do it like how do you stay
consistent how do you figure out how to
work hard but also work smart on
accomplishing your mission so
let's get it started first off you have
to actually love the thing right I mean
how many times have you started a
business because you thought it was
going to make you a lot of money
be honest I've done it too you started
business because you think it's going to
make you money
and then you quickly get bored of it you
quickly realize it's not making you
money and you don't want to do it
anymore
and you close it down and move on to the
next thing and so many people are just
opportunity hopping
jump to the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing the next thing
the next thing without ever actually
loving any of the things and so you
never you never actually win you might
make a little bit of money here and
there you know you might be able to pay
some of your bills off it's great but
you're not living the life that you want
because you're just opportunity hopping
instead of actually finding the thing
that you love doing we're the number one
rule for Success if you watch any of my
videos we've covered so many people take
my word for it or go do your own
research the number one number one guys
number one rule for success is that you
have to love
work that you're doing
it doesn't feel like work because you
like it so much making videos doesn't
feel like work because I like it because
I like the process I like making it I I
like making this video more than
getting something like this right it's
great hey a million subscribers awesome
or the other channel is great
but I like I like the feeling of making
this video and knowing that you right
now are watching it
that means something to me I like it
that's why I keep going otherwise it's
crazy you know
10 000 videos plus later why like how do
you keep going because I like it doesn't
feel like work to me I talk about it
when I do interviews like how people ask
me how have you not burnt out already
like so many people are burning out on
YouTube but well it's not just YouTube
It's entrepreneurship people burn out of
Entrepreneurship not just having a
YouTube channel why do you burn out of
Entrepreneurship because you stop
actually liking there's too much of the
work that you're doing that you don't
like anymore
right there's too much of the work that
you're doing you might still love the
vision for where you're going if you
don't know the vision you got to get out
ASAP
but you might still love the vision but
you're just taking on too much activity
that you don't like doing anymore
so when I'm talking to somebody on their
podcast I like I like doing interviews
it makes me happy it brings me joy to
try to
hit somebody else's audience right they
try to spread believe to an even wider
net
and so if I'm talking to somebody say
well what is this work for you because
in talking to you this doesn't work for
me
this is fun
I'm Gonna Leave This interview with more
energy than I came in that's a sign that
you're doing the right thing so I like
this thank you you're you're giving me
you know I'm giving you content and
exposure for your channel but you're
giving me a gift because
this is fun you're giving me more energy
it doesn't feel like work
the second it starts to feel like work
you have to adjust and it might be it
might be a big adjustment maybe you
shouldn't be doing your business anymore
period because you just opportunity
hopping you don't actually love the
thing
or maybe you just need to make a minor
adjustment and realize okay this makes
sense as a strategy but it's just not
the right strategy for me I need to move
on and do something else even though it
works with some other people it's not me
I don't want to do it so that's how we
start transitioning to working smart
right so working hard is you showing up
every day working towards your goals but
that your purpose means something to you
and that the work you do you actually
enjoy and having fun in the working
smart is then figuring out
there's so many different ways to win
inside your industry there's so many
different ways to win there's so many
people who have won
and there's not just one path this is
where we get locked up is feeling like I
have to do it this way but you don't
actually love doing it that way
and the second you start taking things
on because you think it's the smart
thing to do but you have no interest in
doing it you will never win you will
never win doing work that you hate it's
not going to happen you will never win
doing work that you hate you'll say that
you'll do whatever it takes you won't
you'll quit you'll give up on it because
you don't like it
chasing the goal alone is not enough we
have to actually enjoy the process of
getting to the goal that the process
becomes more important than the goal
gives you more satisfaction and
happiness and pleasure than hitting the
goal how many times have you hit a goal
and then been disappointed after right
he's like oh what's next sometimes
borderline depression right
Ted Turner's dad had a goal to hit a
million dollars he did it and then he
killed himself because he thought things
were going to change but he realized his
life was still the same
so having goals are really good and
important but more important than the
goal is the process of accomplishing the
goal you have to actually like the work
so how do you be smart well you have to
you have to do things that bring value
to people that you also enjoy
so in the course of my career on YouTube
at least said
got a bunch of great compliments the two
that stand out in this context are
garyvee and Ed mylett where garyvee said
I'm the content DJ that inspires people
and said hey you watch so many videos
and then DJ it to inspire people and Ed
mylett said
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
that Napoleon Hills the the greatest
person in person development history and
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
now when they both sat down like
I'm still working on receiving
compliments so I was kind of Blown Away
by both of them and then I asked hey
well can I use that in my in my bio or
my profiles but what what I do is
I love I love modeling success you know
it's why I make all this content it's
why it's why I have all these people you
know behind me on the wall you know we
got we got Steve Jobs and EPI giannini
and my parents and Howard Schultz and
Kanye West like I love modeling success
and I and I want to share my own voice
my own thoughts my own opinions my own
learnings my own stories my own lessons
and somewhere in that mix is now Evan
Carmichael
or some people are if you look at Gary
or Ed or whoever else they're they're
just sharing their own thoughts for the
most part they might have guests on the
interviews they might occasionally have
a quote from somebody else but it's it's
their own views and opinions
I never needed to be the guy you know I
like sharing other people's stuff I like
sharing what I learned from their story
and and I've reluctantly kind of stepped
forward to share my own I used to think
nobody would care about my story or
what I had to say or why would you care
about me when I'm showcasing Elon Musk
like who am I but people kept asking for
my story where I came from so I started
sharing it more and so in that mix
became Evan Carmichael that's how I'm
different than everybody else same thing
for you
you know what do you love doing that
then can also bring value to other
people and what combinations of things
can you bring together instead of
thinking I can do this or I can do this
in the mix is your next great
opportunity
when you can take two or three of your
interests and not do them as the or
right instead of thinking or you think
and
instead of or or you think ain't and but
not three different businesses this is
where people get tripped up it's not
three different businesses it's one
business that does all three of those
things combined in a way that nobody
else has done it before
because nobody can replicate that
the thing that you love doing or the
things that you love doing smush
together that don't make sense for
anybody else is and that is how you're
going to end up winning that's how
you're going to win
James alticher calls it idea sex so you
have one idea and another idea and they
have sex and then out comes your your
great idea
I like it
that's how you start working smart
so working hard as you take it in
working hard if you're not willing to
work hard you're just not ever going to
win period how do you work hard well you
actually have to like the work so it
doesn't feel like work that Jerry
Seinfeld calls it the torture you can
endure that is torture for other people
but for you he's like this is I like
this this is fun this doesn't feel like
torture yeah if making the idea of
making 10 000 videos 12 000 videos
whatever
that would be torture for a lot of
people it's like okay that's cool I like
it let's go let's make another ten
thousand let's keep going and then
inside of that is what do you love doing
that can bring value to other people in
a way that only you can do it by mixing
some of the things your passions your
interest together that have never been
mixed before together in that unique way
that's how you're gonna win instead of
saying that that's not practical instead
of saying that
um they're two different businesses
instead of saying nobody's gonna care no
no no that's how you're gonna win
you mix those things together
focus on how you can use that mix to
bring value to your customers
and now nobody can touch you for people
who say people message me and say hey
Evan this person is copying you this
person is also doing top 10 rules of
success this person is like I don't care
like I spend zero time thinking about
that because if you
are just trying to be Evan Carmichael
you're never going to be here from
Carmichael right the most you're going
to be is an Evan Carmichael Jr
instead of trying to be an Elvis
impersonator go make your own music
right so anybody who's just trying to
copy me I don't I don't care about it
it's the people who are creating new
Innovative things that I consider it to
be the real competition
hard work is your ticket in
you have to love what you're doing that
allows you to keep going
then you have to figure out inside of
what you love how can you combine your
interests your passions your special
things that make you a special unique
Snowflake and bring value to people
and when you figure that out that's the
unique angle of working hard plus
working smart that won't even feel like
you're
working hard or even working that smart
you're just doing you
and helping people
and that's how you win
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there Step number one is cut out
negativity just cut out the people who
don't serve you sometimes those are
friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university you're in the Friendship out
of convenience now there's a lot of
people who you might need